nous pouvons vous annoncer que vous
venez de signer avec Bernard tapille à
l'Olympique de Marseille 6 septembre
1990 France Becken Bower devient
l'entraîneur de l'Olympique de Marseille
le rêve de Bernard tapi président de
l'OM se réalise et l'officialisation est
faite en direct au 20h de TF1 je crois
que c'est ça tient peut-être à la
personne de Bernard tapi qui est
quelqu'un de très volontaire qui m'a
convaincu de prendre son équipe
l'entourage de Marseille me semble tout
à fait parfait qui est un président
parfait et une très bonne équipe l'OM de
Marseille fait partie des meilleures
équipes d'Europe et il y a un public
très enthousiaste là-bas et pour moi
c'était véritablement un challenge que
de prendre cette équipe à l'époque le
Kaiser vient de devenir champion du
monde quelques semaines plus tôt avec
l'Allemagne un nouveau trophée pour
celui qui était déjà double Ballon d'or
puis Champion du Monde 1974 en tant que
joueur à Marseille sur le vieux port
c'est l'effervescence c'est une autre
dimension pour la ville pour le
football et c'est presque des
obligations pour les supporters il va
falloir être aussi bon supporter
que la classe France et Gérard Gérard et
France car ici on n'oublie pas Gérard g
nous sommes contents que
vine mais nous sommes contents que G
reste
aussi Mme enfant du pays il a qume tenu
l'équipe toujours sur du pavé nous en
sommes fiers mais la cohabitation entre
l'entraîneur actuel Gérard Gil et France
Beckenbauer va rapidement prendre fin et
Gérard G qui vient d'offrir à l'OM le
doubl coupe championnat quelques mois
plus tôt décide de claquer la porte 13h
aujourd'hui bref poignée de main entre
Gérard g et FR
benbower la collaboration souhaitée par
Bernard tapi entre les deux hommes
n'aura duré que le temps d'un match G a
sans doute estimé que les perspectives
n'étaient plus satisfaisantes pour lui à
Marseille alors dans la nuit il a pris
sa décision il quitte l'OM après une
longue et difficile réflexion et après
concertation avec Bernard tapi nous
avons pris la décision d'un commun
accord de mettre un terme aux fonction
que j'occupe à l'Olympique de
Marseille je suis vraiment désolé c'est
dommage car c'est quelqu'un de très
sympathique et j'aurais aimé travailler
avec lui maintenant il a choisi de
quitter l'équipe c'est C décision et je
le regrette sincèrement les débuts de
Becken Bower sur le banc sont difficiles
premier match première défaite face à
Cann 1 à 0 et après 9 matchs l'équipe
Championne en titre compte déjà trois
défaites de quoi inquiéter Bernard tapi
qui prévient son entraîneur si je l'ai
fait venir c'est pour faire justement un
football différent avec un état d'esprit
différent avec un mode d'entraînement
différent et mon problème à moi
aujourd'hui il est de savoir si cette
communication différente avec les
joueurs sera en mesure de donner ses
fruits avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
c'est-à-dire avant que finalement lui et
moi on constate qu'il y a une trop
grande différence d'appréciation entre
le football allemand et le football
français France bcken Bower a déserté le
vestiaire de Nancy une heure après le
match à l'issue d'une longue discussion
avec Michel Platini le Kaiser a
seulement félicité Nancy venu à
Marseille pour gagner la Coupe d'Europe
sa mission de fait peut s'arrêter dès
mercredi soir en cas d'échec la greffe
allemande ne prendra finalement pas à
Marseille en décembre 1990 en désaccord
avec Bernard tapi ber présente sa
démission après seulement 15 matchs il
est finalement remplacé par raymondals
le Kaiser devient quant à lui directeur
sportif du
club reprend un peu le rôle de comment
en France un
Didier et ce qui sont directeur
technique qui s'occupent d'un tas
d'affaires dans le club mais la
sélection le ban com on dit et
c'estàdire le travail de groupe ça c'est
pour moi le technicien belge guidera
l'OM vers le Graal une victoire en
finale de Ligue des Champions en